[Music]
foreign
s of anticipation the new Little Mermaid
film finally released to theaters over
the weekend as expected the film is
garbage and I can offer that review
despite not seeing it for the same
reason that I don't need to go order a
Whopper at the new Burger King down the
street in order to assess the quality of
the food I already know that the fries
will be lukewarm and Soggy the bun on
the burger will also be soggy the Mayo
will be scalding hot because they put
the whole thing in the microwave and the
entire meal will be 3 500 calories but
I'll still be hungry 45 minutes after
eating it because the food is made out
of congealed grease and has no
substantive nutritional value I also
know that the employee who serves me the
food will scowl at knee because he hates
every customer who commits the sin of
trying to patronize The Establishment
where he works he'll also speak in a
barely audible Mumble so that I have no
idea whether he even got my order or not
and then when the food comes out it'll
be clear that he didn't get the order
right but I'll just leave with the wrong
order because it's not worth the trouble
of trying to get a practically cataconic
customer service worker to correct the
mistake take without making additional
mistakes on top of it that is the Burger
King experience no matter which location
you happen to be patronizing and the
same goes for Disney's cash grab remix
and for almost everything that Disney
produces even if they aren't remakes
because after all
it's not like Disney only makes remakes
they also make sequels
and they make sequels three makes and
they make remakes of sequels
altogether Disney is the fast food of
the Cinematic World they churn out the
same sludge over and over and over again
there is no creativity there is no
artistic inspiration nobody involved has
any love or interest uh for or in the
the projects that they're working on
that's the point like nobody involved in
it actually cares about the story the
people involved in The Little Mermaid
remake had all the creative passion as
the as the the working the guy who work
in the fry machine at the Burger King
it's the same kind of thing
Disney isn't trying to sell great tell
great stories anymore they're just
pumping out content for the masses and
things for us to mindlessly consume
that's all they care about
that's how I know the little mermaid is
bad because there's not one single
person involved in the project who cares
about making it good
I also know it's bad because the reviews
say so and it's not that I trust what
reviewers say of course it's that I
trust what they don't say
you can't tell much about a movie by
reading what the critics write but you
can often tell everything you need to
tell by reading what's in between the
lines in this case the reviewers have
generally agreed that the little mermaid
is derivative and pointless and
unnecessary and dull and it has dreary
animation and some subpar voice acting
yet they've given the film High marks
anyway based on The Sensational
performance of the lead actress Hallie
Bailey the critics they wouldn't dream
of outright panning a film starring a
black Little Mermaid they have to find a
way to like it otherwise they'll be
racist
and these are always the most damning
reviews not the ones where critics give
the film a thumbs down but the ones
where they're where they're contorting
themselves into all kinds of ungodly
shapes in order to find a way to not
give it a thumbs down
though some critics were more forthright
in their criticism the New York Times
review from film critic Wesley Morris
does praise the movie of course for its
uh diversity and Noble intentions but it
says that it's it's missing some things
specifically Morris laments that the
story lacks quote Joy fun mystery risk
and flavor
and that all makes sense so far the
Disney content engine is specifically
designed to avoid risk and instead
produce fun content that is entirely
devoid of fun
but Wesley goes further
he also says that Kink is missing
yes Wesley Morris of the New York Times
feels deeply wounded that the new Little
Mermaid movie is not kinky
it apparently does not highlight any
deviant sexual practices there are no
fetishes put on display or even
discussed and Morris is surprised by
this I guess those of us who have seen
Disney trajectory in recent years may be
sort of surprised by it too but the
difference is that we are pleasantly
surprised whereas Morris Grieves
you can't believe he's so sad that
there's no kinkiness in Little Mermaid
people are raving about genucel products
my Show's editor Jeff can't live without
geniusell's wide range of products if he
didn't use genucel daily he would look
like a lifeless corpse sitting in front
of a monitor day in and day out nothing
works like geniusell it's a family
recipe that's perfected over 20 years by
a compounding pharmacist who works in
small Badges and with only safe natural
cruelty free ingredients which is is
always so important to me just in time
for the warm weather our friends at
janisl are including two Springtime
Essentials in their most popular package
the ultra retinal and Dark Spot
Corrector Ultra retinal contains a
powerful retinal alternative that is
safe for your skin their Dark Spot
Corrector will help reduce sunspots plus
you'll still get genu sales world-class
under eye bag therapy to help alleviate
puffiness geniusell promises immediate
effects you'll see results in 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back a try
genucel's most popular package for 70
off at genucel.com Walsh YT
all orders are upgraded to free shipping
and every subscription order includes a
complimentary spring spa box with free
spa essential so go to genucel.com
walshyt jennycell.com Welsh YT
now this criticism is bizarre and gross
to say the least and it was originally
going to be the actual subject of this
cancellation
but plans changed when I stumbled upon
something else related to the the new
little mermaid um
apparently Disney did not simply remake
their own film shot by shot they did
change a few things they made the cast
more diverse of course they also added a
couple of songs they changed some of the
original songs to make them more
politically correct and inoffensive to
the modern ear but they also added one
or two new numbers
one of the new numbers is um a song
performed by the seagull character
voiced by a comedian who goes by the
stage name Aquafina
now this song has gone viral over the
past couple of days but not for the
reasons that Disney would prefer
I'm not going to make you listen to very
long but I can only play a very short
snippet of this anything longer will
violate copyright laws also probably the
the Geneva Convention but um here it is
listen
hey wake up wake up wake up what hey
have you not heard that scatter back no
the gossip the buzz the who said what
who does that yeah that's cattle but
well I was flying over land and seeing
ear to the ground then I came flying
here for you to see and hear what I
found remember that's why I'm remember
my song and I swap and I was like
I remember well ever since the what's
his name the guy with the hair in the
shirt the prince yeah the prince has
been dropping his
no
in some ways this is an appropriate song
for The Little Mermaid because listening
to it makes me want to throw myself into
the sea uh words cannot capture just how
terrible it is if I heard this song
and then over the next 12 hours my house
burned down and I lost my job and I was
diagnosed with a terminal illness
the song would still be the worst thing
that happened to me that day if I had a
time machine I would go back in time and
kill the person who invented music
before they had could invent it just to
prevent this song from being made it
would be better to erase music from
human history altogether than to allow
this song to exist
this song you know it sounds like it
sounds like what might happen if you put
a group of deaf schizophrenics into a
room with a keyboard and a bunch of pots
and pans and recorded the random noises
that they produced
and what makes this so especially
Sinister is that little kids will watch
this movie
and the intelligent children with good
taste will hear that song and they will
cry and they will turn to their parents
and say why is this happening mommy
please make the bad sounds go away
but the less Discerning children might
like the song and then they'll spend the
next seven months listening to it on
repeat as their parents slowly go insane
there will be parents who play this song
in the car in order to satisfy their
whiny kids which will create extremely
unsafe road conditions
I mean texting while driving is
dangerous driving Under the Influence is
even more dangerous
but most dangerous of all is to subject
yourself to psychological torture while
trying to drive a minivan full of kids
down the highway
that's what's going to happen now
what I'm trying to say is that I don't
like the song and the most damning thing
I can say about it is that it perfectly
represents the modern Disney
when people utterly bereft of creative
skill try to create something of Their
Own
this is what you end up with it's like
if one of the to go back to the Burger
King analogy it's like if one of the
teenage fry Cooks at Burger King
actually tried to make a unique dish
using the ingredients available in the
kitchen
you'd end up with some ungodly
Abomination that makes the Soggy Whopper
look edible by comparison
so there's a reason these companies just
stick to the formula all they have is
the formula they don't have the ability
to do anything different or interesting
Disney has chased all the real artistic
talents away
they're left with a woman who borrows
her stage name from a bottled water
company
and and this is what you get from her
there are creative people left in the
world are there artists out there who
make great films make beautiful music
other forms of art they do exist good
art still exists
it's just that you're not going to get
it from Disney
and that is why Disney is in the end
once again canceled that'll do it for
this portion of shows and move over to
the members block you can become a
member today by using Code wall should
check out for two months free on all
annual plans hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed